oh my god everybody we got a freak out
about cable it looks like they found the
actor so I'm explaining what's going on
stranger things have happened in the
Deadpool universe so what's going on the
reason people are freaking out is
because David Harbor the actor who plays
the sheriff and stranger things season
two is being tested for a cable because
there's so much big Deadpool stuff
dropping this weekend I'm doing a
special Logan giveaway it's for two gift
certificates for the movie all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video now because the
movie is such a big deal they're looking
at a bunch of different people but they
usually don't announce stuff like this
until it's in the final running so he
looks like their leading candidate
unless somebody else comes along and
usually that doesn't happen usually it's
like hey you know this is the guy we're
looking at it was the same deal just a
little while ago when they were looking
at Matt Reeves to direct the Batman
movie they said he is in talks to direct
Batman it was really just like waiting
for him to sign on the dotted line so
Fox is getting all their ducks in a row
before they start shooting and there is
a Deadpool 2 teaser trailers that
they've already shot we know about this
footage that we'll be playing this
weekend so I'll explain that in a second
there's going to be a lot of Deadpool
and Logan stuff happening this weekend
but if you haven't watched stranger
things david Harbor is actually an
amazing actor he was hilarious at the
Golden Globes everybody was going crazy
about Winona Ryder they did his crazy
meme and he had the greatest response to
it just like oh my god this is the
greatest thing ever you have to listen
to his actual speech from that ceremony
this totally sounds like a cable speech
he is on fire this award from you who
take your craft seriously and earnestly
believe like me that great acting can
change the world is a call to arms from
our fellow craft men and women to go
deeper and through our art to battle
against fear self-centeredness and
exclusivity of our predominantly
narcissistic culture and through our
craft to cultivate a more empathetic and
understanding society by revealing
intimate truths that
as a forceful reminder to folks that
when they feel broken and afraid and
tired they are not alone we are united
in that we are all human beings and we
are all together on this horrible
painful joyous exciting and mysterious
ride that is being alive now as we act
in the continuing narrative of stranger
thing we 1983 Midwestern will repel
bullies we will shelter freaks and
outcasts those who have no home we will
get past the lies we will come monsters
and when we are lost amidst the
hypocrisy and the casual violence of
certain individuals and institutions we
will have perceived Jim hopper punch
some people in the face when they
destroy life and we will do it all with
soul record and with joy we thank you
for this responsibility [ __ ] you can you
not picture that guy as cable now but I
feel like this speech especially in such
a public area in front of so many people
at such a topical way just totally sand
those flames so we someone who can do
comedy really well he can do drama
really well stranger things is more of a
drama but the thing about this is that
him playing cable sort of reminds me
stranger things style Messiah Complex
hope with 11 because he sort of
emotionally adopts 11 because his
daughter has died when the series picks
up so even though I don't think that
they're going to be doing that with
cable during the Deadpool movie you just
have to imagine him running around with
the cable sideburns and the white hair
just towing 11 around strapped to his
chest just going crazy with his giant
gun but where they have explained about
cable in the movie is that they will be
streamlining his backstory because it's
the first time we're going to be seeing
cable they will be true to his original
first appearance in the comics now there
are a couple firsts that he had there
was the first time he appeared and then
there was the first time he appeared as
cable so the very first appearance was
as a baby and uncanny x-men then a
little while later in the New Mutants
comic book in issue number 86 like very
and very brief the first real
issue that he appeared in was New
Mutants number 87 that next issue
so then Deadpool showed up in issue
number 98 just a couple months after
that so you have cable showing up saying
that he's from the future training a
team to fight the forces of strife and
apocalypse is this really
post-apocalyptic story it's very
inspired by a terminator because that
movie came out in 1984 just came out in
1990 so Rob Liefeld probably a big
Terminator fan no surprises there so it
sort of reads like that they set up the
conflict with stripe and then all you
learn is they just a total badass is as
crazy drill-sergeant that's trained them
to fight the mute Liberation Front which
is stripes team from the future
so then Deadpool shows up later to
assassinate him
hired by Tolliver and it's a relatively
simple issue he just shows up to kill
cable he just hired to do a hit that's
all the backstory they have together but
then obviously later in the comics they
develop this crazy friendship where
cable is either tracking down Deadpool
to stop him from doing something crazy
or they have to team up to stop
something crazy from happening but as
far as the story goes for the movie you
guys can let me know what you want them
to do if they like sort of winnow it
down to something that's much more basic
what do you want them to cut out I feel
like they can leave stripe for way later
they can just have cable be a time
traveler they don't have to do the
legacy virus right away they can tease
that in because it's very mr. sinister
oriented in they're working up to mr.
sinister in the main x-men film the
producers already confirm that they do
have mr. sinister plan but he'll
probably show up in the main x-men films
first before he shows up in Deadpool if
he ever does show up in that pool I just
did a Deadpool a2 video about how I
think they can use mr. sinister in his
corporation without actually having to
use the character himself in the same
way that they use the x-men mansion
without actually going inside the x-men
mansion that much it is one of the
advantages of the comedy of Deadpool you
can make fun of the fact that you can't
do the big character that you should be
doing like oh you know we can't really
go inside here discount x-mansion
because we don't have the budget for it
but I totally think that this stranger
things actor is a solid pick for them
he's a great actor and he's well within
their budget and I think that's the
whole thing here is that people were
like what about Russell Crowe it was an
interesting idea but he's like a 20
million dollar actor and that would be
like half of their
they are spending more money than they
did on the first movie that was about 58
million dollars for the production
budget they spent way more marketing the
film but just because it was such a big
success doesn't mean they're going to
walk out and spend a hundred and fifty
million dollars making the sequel
they'll still keep it under a hundred
million dollars I'm expecting it to be
somewhere around like 75 million so
it'll probably happen with the cable
casting because they want to get into
production as fast as possible they're
tweaking the script locking down their
actors is that in the next week or two
they will confirm who's playing cable
they'll say okay this guy's playing in
or if somebody else comes along that
they think is better they'll cast him
but just the way they're talking about
it sounds like it is going to be David
Harper it just hasn't absolutely been
confirmed yet as of me posting this
video but to explain the Deadpool 2
trailer that they shot so everybody was
wondering if there was some sort of post
credits scene for Logan and then the
director came out and was like
absolutely not I did not shoot any
Deadpool stuff there's no post credit
scene so everyone's just wondering what
the truth is is he just misleading us is
there something else that's going to be
attached later so there was a promo that
was shot with Deadpool in Ryan Reynolds
what they did is they shot it separately
and it's a Deadpool two teaser trailer
for that movie that has nothing to do
with the Logan movie that they'll be
airing this weekend in front of Logan if
they drop it online I will totally do a
breakdown even if they don't I'll do a
breakdown but because most people
haven't seen the movie yet always to
post that I've had a chance to see it
Stanley is in it it's totally hilarious
is exactly what you would expect from
the Deadpool marketing team they won an
award for their marketing campaign they
sold that movie better than anybody sold
any movie last year it was great so I
cannot wait to see what they do to
market Deadpool - there'll be all kinds
of crazy stuff happening but just keep
in mind that they actually almost spent
twice as much marketing the film as they
did actually making it they spent almost
like ninety million dollars marketing
that film which is like the marketing
budget of a big blockbuster film
congratulations to the latest Logan
giveaway winner t-bone 284 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you win gift certificates for
the movie so I'll announce the winner of
that Deadpool giveaway when I post the
Deadpool a teaser video tomorrow
hopefully they drop the footage
they don't all still post a video
explaining what it is it'll also be
posting my spoilery Logan reviews so be
sure and go see the movie this weekend
while you wait for that you can click
here for my Logan review video and you
can click here for the Deadpool
to Cesar all updates the link as soon as
I post s thank you so much watching but
I thought I'll see you guys in the next
video